good morning everyone uh
what I want to talk today about is
really the lessons that I've learned and
taken away from building in a number of
different environments and to start with
that I think one of the first things to
kind of think about is how did we get
here as a community it's pretty
phenomenal what we as a collective group
have been able to do and are doing but
it's kind of a question of like how did
we get here and so if we kind of take a
quick stroll back through time where did
data science really come from and I
think most of the world kind of thinks
about this history of data science
really starting from this point in
Moneyball and this kind of like hey we
could do something pretty special if
baseball can do it sure we should be
able to do it in our companies but one
of the really powerful things about this
is that data science actually started a
long time ago and there's a lot of
places where we forget where data
science really came from and one of
those places I first think about is like
the Mayans and how they were taking
these very powerful well it's doing
these computations without the
sophistication of the computational
cloud infrastructure that we're so used
to to actually make these Celestial
predictions and figure out how to think
about the crop and forecasting or let's
think about the Indus Valley and what
was being built out there in this
phenomenal uh large-scale structures to
do similar type activities so it's
incredible precision
and we often forget about the women at
Bletchley Park a World War II who
actually are really the superpower
behind saving the world in many ways the
world as we know it they were using not
only these computational infrastructure
like like uh Colossus and Enigma and
those type of efforts but they were also
the actual computers that's where the
term computers really were being used
was these are the women if you ever have
a chance to actually in the UK to go out
to Buckley Park and if you're fortunate
enough to meet any of the women that are
still there who give tours they are the
ones who actually did this work
and then where did some of the real big
initial push that we are sitting on top
of that we really we got to live was 9
11.
because at 9 11 that time period of what
happened was there was this question of
how do we find the signal in the noise
and where is that happening and so many
of us who were in that who were starting
our careers in that time period got to
work on these 911 questions saying how
could we bring very disparate data
sources together to actually find signal
and we found that there weren't tools
there weren't techniques and so we had
to go ahead and make them and many of us
as we were doing that actually
transitioned to Industry where we
started to realize that a number of
things were coming together not just the
computational abilities but storage open
source and talent was really coming
about together some of this was in the
cloud some of this was burgeoning in on
on-prem clouds all of this was happening
simultaneously and one of the places
where we saw this really start to take
off was when our efforts at LinkedIn
where we really had the opportunity not
just to be a technology team but to be
one of the first product teams working
on data where we were responsible for
profit loss engagement all the different
components and we had the opportunity
where people like Jonathan Goldman was
came up with this idea of people you may
know and figure that out and that just
became ubiquitous across every social
network around there including Facebook
and all the others at that time
or we built out these products like who
viewed my profile it turned out to be a
not only one of the big drivers of
engagement on the site but also turned
out to be a strong Revenue generation
this is a prototype that was actually of
the original full-blown feature it was
built by Chris rickamini and Steve
Stegman
we also had
Amazon showing these ideas of
collaboration collaborative filters to
saying hey people who bought this bought
this type of thing all these different
versions were starting to take place and
we were actually going hey wait a second
these are actual new kind of data
products that were providing large value
job recommendation system started to
show up this is Monica regatti's first
prototype of this which showed like
maybe we could actually give up and
serve give recommendations to people
and that we could show and start to
visualize very complex aspects of data
this was a LinkedIn graph that we built
some of you may have seen this as what
was called in maps at the time being
able to visualize your network and how
everyone was related together
and this we realized was a new form of
talent that was starting to take place
we're starting to realize that there's a
new thing here and we didn't actually
know what to exactly call ourselves how
Varian had started to talk about this a
while before saying the sexiest job in
the next 10 years will be statisticians
and we were realizing like well we
should call something like that but we
had a problem well if you call ourselves
statisticians the economists are going
to get kind of pissed off
and what about everybody else that's not
a stat like we so we were getting to
this this identity crisis of what do we
call ourselves
and this is a time period where Jeff
hammerbacher was running the Facebook
data team and myself would meet
regularly to compare notes on what
technologies were working what wasn't
working and we started to ask like I
should ask just this question like what
are you guys going to call yourselves
because HR is coming to us and saying
hey you got to have a name for
yourselves
and I was saying like while we have all
why can't we have all these titles and
they said look the engineers are
engineering
designers and designers sales of sales
what are you guys going to be and so we
had this problem of saying what could we
be and Jeff had this we started to build
out this list of different titles and
Jeff had this idea of data scientists
and he said it's kind of redundant
why should we do that and so I took it
back to the team and Monica regatti had
this great idea she's like well we're
LinkedIn why don't we test every
different job title
like why not just post it and see what
happens and so we posted and guess what
everyone applied to
data scientist
so guess what we decided to call
ourselves data scientists and when this
happened we realized that there was
really something special going on Drew
Conway put out this Venn diagram the
same you might remember saying hey
there's this data science thing here
with hacking skills we're going to put
in this Venn diagram format Hillary
Mason one of my co-authors on the number
of uh of the many books also put out
this Venn diagram about what we were and
how to think about us as awesome nerds
and
Harvard Business Review said hey there's
a big thing happening so we should
actually have a whole issue dedicated to
Big Data and we were asked to actually
write an article and we wrote this
article Tom Davenport and I wrote this
article and here's the thing we wrote
this article about arguing why you need
a data scientist
and we had a title that was something
like why every organization should care
about data and Harvard Business Review
said scratch that we're taking a lesson
from the Kardashians we're going to
figure out how to make this click bait
and so they titled it data scientist a
sexiest job of the 21st Century
this has now become one of the in the
top
100 most downloaded articles ever in
Harvard Business review history
and it just was it's been about 10 years
since we we released this and it was
kind of as stunning how much this took
took everything in all these Executives
saying yeah I need a data science team I
need how do I do this who are these
people where do we find them where can
we recruit them from and you know you
saw these articles these job postings
saying hey you need to have 10 years of
data science experience and we're like
how do you have 10 years when we just
labeled it last year I was at work uh so
like this was taking off and then what
we saw is Monica actually produced this
graph of we use the LinkedIn data to
kind of get a sense of how many people
were starting to label them around this
and we saw this unbelievable uptick
taking place as people were really
saying wait we could do something
special with data
and then that led to this moment
hi everybody
normally I'd begin these remarks with a
joke about data science but about half
the stuff my staff came up with was
below average
but as all of you know understanding and
innovating with data has the potential
to change the way we do almost anything
for the better
that's why my administration's opened up
massive amounts of government data to
the public for the first time with more
than 135
000 data sets available for download at
data.gov
think about the weather and map apps we
check every day on our phones many of
which are powered by open government
data along with countless other apps and
services
or our new Precision medicine initiative
which joins data science and Healthcare
to accelerate treatments for disease
we want more Americans to dream up and
deploy Innovations like these to solve
problems save lives and create new jobs
and opportunities
that's why I'm so pleased to welcome Dr
DJ Patel as the federal government's
first Chief data scientist and that's
why I'm asking you to help
as DJ likes to say data science is a
team sport
that's why we want you America's data
scientists to join us in this effort
help us build better Digital Services
for the American people help us unleash
new innovation in areas like health care
and climate change
help us change this country and this
world for the better
thanks
so what happened in that moment why what
President Obama say we need to have
a a person in the White House Forever on
going forward for what this should be
for for like that the president needs a
chief data scientist his president needs
their own version of Spock in the
situation room or any key meeting around
data yes I did that
the the part the reason of that is
fundamentally spelled out in this
mission statement to responsibly Unleash
the Power of data to benefit all
Americans and this was very carefully
chosen the word responsibly and all
Americans just because we can doesn't
mean we should and we're having real
questions about that right now on AI and
a number of other Technologies and how
do we ensure that it benefits everybody
that is the mission statement that U.S
Chief data scientist and it is a
bipartisan aspect
it's there embedded in the the the for
the White House whichever presidency in
the Trump Administration actually worked
hard to try to hire somebody they ran
into some challenges
and then now there is a U.S Chief data
scientist Denise Ross who is the current
uh uh U.S Chief data scientist for
President Biden and the reason the
president realized this is we are
entering an era where all this comp the
compute the data everything comes
together in a way that the presidency
must have someone that they can ask to
give this advice at at moment's hand of
Crisis or figuring out National policy
or thinking about all the issues and
that really was the AHA of President
Obama to do that and I had the privilege
of taking that role and so one of the
questions to ask here why has taken data
scientists as a term taken off why has
data science taken off
the first is as I think we see with data
science is because we people are seeing
that value proposition of what we can
create
the fact that we can actually produce
tangible things that people interact
with even if they are digital objects
even if it's a people who may know a
jobs recommendation is adding value to
somebody's life
the second reason I think the data
scientist title has taken off
fundamentally is because honestly no one
knows what it means
now think about it you know one of the
things that I think we've done really
well in industry is we figured out how
to put people in boxes
you're an engineer you're over here if
you're an engineer should you be allowed
to be designed
probably say no you didn't stay in your
lane if you're allowed to do sales no
you're supposed to stay in your lane if
you're a data scientist compared to
business analysts imagine you go to a
certain meeting and you're in that
meeting and you're in business analytics
in analytics or business analytics and
they're like why are you here and you
said you were in one of those two roles
they'd be like hey this is an important
meeting you shouldn't really be here
if you're the data scientist and you're
in that meeting they're like oh thank
God somebody brought somebody smart to
this meeting
and then what happens
you have context
and when you have context
now you can have impact you can take
your skills you can take this that is
all this us rest the stuff that's going
on
and apply it
kid you not the number of times I was in
a meeting at the White House where
people were like
why is DJ here
like they're like okay we get that he's
the chief data scientist and then but
what's what's he supposed to do on
Criminal Justice Reform or policing why
is he here and then by the end they'd be
like
oh
you have all these ideas like how are we
going to address body camera for example
when body cameras first came up in this
questions that happened around the
killings of of Michael Brown and many
other people of color the questions of
body cameras came up and we asked a
simple question around that table which
is
what's going to be the privacy policy
around that data
what are we going to do when there's
kids in that footage
what about
somebody who might be a potential victim
who might receive further threats
typically a spouse who's a victim of
domestic violence what are we going to
do in those situations who's going to
pay for the cost of bandwidth not just
the cost of the devices
and then by the end of the meeting was
like oh that's why we don't invite DJ
those are the kind of questions that
would come up and that's why you need
this but the fundamental thing about
this is It's the power because we are a
horizontal
we aren't just a vertical
and by being that horizontal allows this
unbelievable latitude to be effective
and so I want to talk a little bit about
the problems ahead and the problems that
I see
the way I think about what is happening
from the privilege that I have had with
the people I've been able to work with
for the things I think we should do
and at first I want to tell you the
story of Jennifer Bitner
and Jennifer uh
she's a really remarkable woman and I
want you to imagine this situation
one day you're walking into the office
and you get handed a note this is a note
I carry with me regularly
and it's by the chief of staff of the
president
and he hands you a note and he says
the president would like
your answer about what we're going to do
so you get the note you're like
not sure what to do with that you kind
of look at it you read it and it starts
like this this is the actual note
Dear Mr President
on April 2nd 2014 at age 36
I was diagnosed with stage four breast
cancer with metastases in my liver lungs
adrenal gland spleen ovaries spine hips
clavicle ribs and many other bones
every oncologist told me and my husband
to get my Affairs in order
one oncologist said I would be in
hospice within three months
I'm the kind of person your Precision
medicine initiative will be helping and
saving
and I want to do whatever I can to help
I come from a middle class family in
Pittsburgh where my father a proud
Vietnam veteran was a telephone lineman
for 40 years and my mother was a
homemaker
I am proud to have worked my way up
to a public vice president role at a
publicly traded health care company
in Austin right here in Austin
ironically I married a cancer biologist
named rod
who is who's while completing his
doctoral work at the Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville Florida
despite both working in health care we
find ourselves at a loss for a long-term
solution to my cancer
the average life expectancy for stage
four breast cancer is three years
three years
I have so much more to give this world
than three years would allow
think about
what you would do if you got handed this
note
you know as a country
we are the country that unlocked the
secrets of the atom
we are the only country that has sent
a probe to every Celestial body
in our solar system
we're the country that discovered the
human genome unlocked the DNA
where the country that receives the most
Nobel prizes
consistently
what would you do
if it was a national security crisis
there's a bombing or a terrorist attack
or anything else
we know what we do
you go to The Situation Room
you call everyone together
you create a national plan
so that's what we did that night
we went down a situation we called
everyone called Francis Collins who head
of the National Institutes of Health
decoded the Human Genome Project a
number of others and we said what are we
going to do for Jennifer Bitner
because it's not just Jennifer Bitner
that we're focused on
every one of us knows a Jennifer Bitner
and unfortunately in this room many of
us not some of us
many of us are going to be a Jennifer
Bittner or have one of our direct loved
ones who is a Jennifer Bittner some of
you are going through this right now
what are we going to do with it and that
became not only the foundation of the
Precision medicine initiative but also
the cancer moonshot
and why would you put the chief data
scientist in charge of that effort
rather than the head of the National
Institutes of Health the guy who decoded
the Human Genome Project it's because
the president recognized we need a
fundamentally different approach to
tackle these problems it has to be a
horizontal
just like the data science components
that we all embody we are horizontal we
have to be able to pull all these things
together and the solutions for this is
not just in the medical records that are
locked up in thousands and thousands of
silos across this country in some
hospital or doctor's database but it's
also locked up inside our ability to
think creatively about how we use data
how do we do it in a safe secure way how
do we do it in a way that is really
fighting for the Jennifer bitner's
those are the problems that are really
ahead of us that kind of capability and
we are started we have started only to
scratch the surface on this because
remember just as we start to figure out
these Solutions we have to make sure
that they work for everybody too
not just one population they got to be
affordable
because you know what's going to suck is
we find that magical solution for
Jennifer
and she can't pay for it
she can't afford it and she can't
receive it
that's equally a death sentence
so let me give you a switch gears and
give you another version of data science
that we're seeing on the front lines
and this one starts on March 14th 2020.
some of you may remember that day very
clearly in your mind I certainly do
because it's Pi Day
[Laughter]
but also something else was happening on
March 14th
at this point in time around the world
we had 65 debts uh 9815 cases
just beginning
here in the United States we had two
cruise ships just beginning to dock in
the U.S with covid uh positive patients
and we really didn't have a clue what's
going on Italy was showing unbelievable
issues starting to show up we had very
little information out of Wuhan and we
were really worried about what was about
to take place
and so I received a call got this call
that said hey what was going to happen
and a bunch of this is featured in this
book by Michael Lewis about premonition
called the premonition and we got a call
that that afternoon saying hey we're
worried about this
what should we do what should be our
strategy and they laid out a strategy
for data and I said that's not what I
would do
and they said what would you do I said
give me a couple hours and we literally
wrote this memo this is the actual memo
that we wrote in two hours
and there's a couple key components of
it the first being hey you know what we
need to have this pragmatic we need an
extremely pragmatic Nimble resource
results oriented strategy that supports
the acquisition of timely data cleaning
of data putting data sets together a
system to look for insights
uh supporting traditional
epidemiologists in mathematical malls
and an evaluation of models as new data
is acquired does that sound familiar to
anybody
you probably had a version of that like
a dozen times in your life for those of
you that are in companies probably like
every one of your pitch decks
it's the same thing whether it's
government or industry it's the same
thing over and over again
but there's another component that we
realized we said we need a team
and we're going to put together a team
we have identified the following data
scientists and Engineers who are ready
to start working immediately on this
Mission they are literally the the very
best in the world for this kind of work
they are ready to start immediately
virtually because we're pulling them
from around the country and it should be
able to travel to Sacramento for work
trips and if we wanted to we were
willing to relocate them for a period of
time
the next question I got on this was how
much is it going to cost
we said cost it's a pandemic what do you
mean costs
we're going to work on this right now
and so we put this team together this is
an initial team this is Todd Park former
U.S CTO of the United States Bob kocher
who uh uh wrote the Affordable Care Act
uh Jenna who designed the software for
uh uh the dragon uh space uh SpaceX
Capital uh Mike Wilkin Secretary of
Health uh charity Dean who is uh the
protagonist and public health official
in uh premonition and figure knew that
coveted was happening issues the first
first person on the boat uh when the
when the uh the cruise ships landed to
figure out what was going on with the
patients and so we put this team
together and we said hey we got to get
this stuff going we got to start
figuring this out and so the first thing
we did is we said just like we
translated this we said we need to have
these five components figured out so if
we're going to start with modeling we
gotta have a model everyone's like what
models
right we got we gotta we need an
epidemiological model we need to do this
and so we realized we didn't exactly
have a model
and what we needed to do was build one
and so we found this model out of uh at
that point in time Justin Lester is a
research scientist at John Hopkins and
he had this pretty sophisticated model
by standards of epidemiology
epidemiology at that time and we said
great can we run it with all the
simulations
and we discovered a slight problem
it was basically running on a grad
student's computer under their desk
and we're like we're gonna decide the
policies of the State of California
the fifth largest economy in the world
on a grad student's computer
that doesn't seem like the best thing so
we had another strategy we said
hey let's get two of our best Engineers
that we could think of and ask them to
help come and help actually three of
them Kit rodolfa who actually designed
the campaign strategy for President
Obama also a health care expert and help
build devoted health
Sam Shaw who helped figure out how to
scale data products and Engineering at
LinkedIn and Josh Wills who was uh many
of you might know from a lot of his
talks around also work at Cloudera and
at slack when we asked I said hey guys
could we come together and build this
and then I made a place to call to
Werner Vogel and I said
Werner I need some compute they said how
much
all of it
how much can you give me and they were
gracious enough to give us as much
compute as possible as well as their
internal teams to build out that model
and that model turned into this the very
first ability to have any insight on
what was happening with covid it also
showed that if we had anything close to
what was taking place in New York and
Italy we were going to be out of beds
instantly and we had only one option
which is to basically buy ourselves time
buy ourselves a little bit of time to
get our health care System to catch up
we had no PPE we did not have enough
reagent to actually do testing we had to
spin up the testing facilities we needed
all of that in place
and that led us to dashboards and we
needed to create those dashboards real
time to give the data to the to the
governor to figure out decisions and the
hospitalists and everybody else and we
turn around and we say guys was your
dashboard technology and guess what we
got
what dashboards
what technology do we have where's the
data pipes none of that stuff existed
the data products all these different
things we realized we didn't have the
infrastructure in place and many of you
also helped start spinning this up and
we realized we needed it all yesterday
and the key thing I have to point out
here is what does it take to actually
respond in a crisis how fast can we go
from zero to sixty and what I think we
found is that we were wanting
our stuff is too hard to actually get to
work with each other are stuffed is too
hard to deploy we love to Pat ourselves
on the back about how awesome we are and
how cool our technology is and it is
cool
but did it actually help us solve things
at the end of the day
that's where we found and that is the
opportunity ahead of us on this data
products we had to figure out and let me
give you an example that we did end up
building this is called Cal cat which is
actually a thing we built specifically
for all those Public Health officials at
the county level who were constantly
under attack from their city council and
under threats death threats literal
death threats and we put the models
together and we said hey here's what we
think is going to happen here's all the
models that we could get as new people
were building out new models from
different states different academic
centers we put it all together
and this is us what gave them ability
because what they were able to do was
then print this out and share it
directly with the with the council to
ask here's how we can make good
decisions here's because we had a strong
tension we have to figure out what we're
doing with our schools we know the
consequences of shutting down schools we
know the economic trade-offs of what
happens when people don't get to go to
work essential workers all these
components
and we had another component of this
that we also realized and this is
something I think we really need to take
away as data scientists we nearly needed
to focus also on what is really
happening on the ground not just that
data aspect as caref cares to freeze had
this idea she said hey you know what
we're getting a lot of traffic to these
these California websites that are
talking about our covet strategy what
happens if we just put a survey on there
and ask people to give us what they're
thinking and it was amazing the response
that would get back to us and so we
started to put its deck together this
day this data briefing insights book
with all the insights that we could find
that were happening around the state or
the country around covid and layering
onto it actual quotes
this became a must read for any policy
maker in California before they went to
bed
was not only looking at the data but
really being able to ask the people get
a sense of what was in people's head the
fear the anxiety the concern doesn't
matter what side of the political
Spectrum you were on but understanding
this this was a data product that got
spun up in real time and added some of
the greatest value in there
and then finally as we think about data
catalog and data sets
was we started to spin this up one of
the things we realized is this like why
we have data but we don't have a way of
putting it together we don't have a way
of doing it so we had to put it together
a data catalog really fast
I didn't have things like data.world I
didn't have things like that that data
Hub uh or Acro I didn't have any of this
stuff and so what do we do
we found that people were putting all
this data in databases and no one was
utilizing it so we said well we're going
to create a data catalog this is
literally our data catalog this
wonderful technology that you're seeing
you might have heard of it it's called
Excel
this became the thing and then it was
basically like if you have a question
email DJ
he will tell you what's happening in the
table
if you see something that's different
call DJ so that he can update the very
sophisticated
data catalog
that's literally it was our state of the
art why not only procurement but the
speed at which it takes to spin up these
Technologies
get it all to work
and then the insights and as I mentioned
that book with the quotations and what
was really going on this is an example
of that that data book what some of the
types of analysis that was happening and
that was really one of the power that we
saw was this unique new united front of
data science that came together we had
all these organizations like the covet
tracking project covet act now U.S
digital response academic programs
crisis ready most of these were all
volunteer efforts there was no Dollars
around this mostly because people were
stuck at home with shutdown orders
nothing else to do
but the power that came together because
we as a community decided to do this
that's what really took off
that's what made the change that was
what was the real power behind covid
that people don't talk about and we need
to I'd be remiss if I didn't bring up
the fact is we're talking about this in
this country that I talked about that
has put an object to every Celestial
body in our solar system
lost one Million Lives due to covet
one million Americans are dead because
of the way we responded to covid
we have a national
crisis around mental health you probably
heard the amazing people at crisis text
line yesterday if you didn't search them
out to talk to them about the work that
they are doing
we've seen an unbelievable impact to
teenagers on this issue we've seen a
backsliding of of gains we've made on
education we've had destroyed economies
small businesses
so how did we do on this
not great
despite having a Playbook post Ebola
but how much worse would it have been if
we weren't there as a team
that's the power that we have as data
scientists we are coming together and
this is really kind of leads to the the
the the the the end of what I think are
the biggest lessons I've learned here
the first is the data points have names
you got to learn their names you gotta
tell their stories you have to remember
that Jennifer bitner's you have to
remember all the people on the front
line that have done work and what
happens
the greatest lesson of this it was
instilled Into Me by President Obama was
that this lesson and one day I was
learning about talking about the updates
around Precision medicine he gave me an
explicit order to say you have to get
out there to the community and know
their stories and I went and I went to
all these foundations and groups that
represent these P populations and got to
got their input and came back to him and
I said here's what they're saying said
did you actually talk to the real people
I said no sir and let me tell you the
last thing you ever want in a life is an
ass kicking in the Oval Office
it is not a good place to live to be at
and I went back and I went and I talked
to the people who were on the ground and
got to hear their stories and what they
were concerned about around their data
whether they wanted their data be used
and it changed my life it changed my
perspective on what was going on and he
was absolutely right President Obama's
spot on that you have to get out there
and know their names so often we love to
when we're building products we have
some Persona we have some amazing
personas personas look like they're like
like who are these happy people no one's
this happy at work no one's this happy
at home like it's like photo frames like
when you go to a store and you're like
who are these people
get out there learn their names learn
their stories let them inspire you see
let them challenge you about the things
that is one of the biggest things that
I've found
two
the small things
it's a small things out there those
small tiny pain points that's what makes
the whole thing break down like in covid
response it's a tiny things that were
the biggest and most challenging and
fundamentally it's just like that data
catalog it's the unsexy work that
creates the biggest impact
those low hanging fruit those are the
blockers but you someone's got to do it
someone's got to roll to sleep why does
it take the US Chief data scientist to
actually write the data catalog because
no one else would do it
so someone's gotta just roll up the
sleeves and do it
some of you may have seen that we
produce these stickers well we wrote a
book Hillary Mason Mike Lucas and I
wrote a book about data ethics and this
was one of the components that really
got stood out and a guy named Dr popular
actually made these made stickers if
anybody if you find me afterwards and
want one just ask me about them I'll
give you one is move purposely and fix
things our strategy should really be
around there are so many things around
our society so many things around our
work environments or other processes
what happens if we adopt this as a
mantra to really move purposely and fix
things
start really getting after things those
small problems start changing it that
way
ask ourselves
we need how do we ensure this technology
works for us not against us what are the
unintended consequences
I had the opportunity to help write and
draft the national AI strategy
which was quickly adopted by China also
because they were like this is so good
we should do it
and now it's built on and many of the
things that we've talked about are the
questions and issues we have at hand
right now and so we have to ask
ourselves how do we do this and I would
assert also that we should think of a
technology as neither radical nor
revolutionary unless it barely benefits
everyone and we're really great at
creating technology but doesn't benefit
everyone what does it take for that
technology to get pushed out to every
Jennifer Bitner out there what would
that look like
and then think bigger
we are all thinking big but I push you
to think bigger because the problems
that you all are capable of the problems
that you all are capable of
is so stunning
and what can we unlock if we push bigger
so you may have seen my blog post about
this announcing when I came to grade
point Ventures the problems I'm focused
on these problems that we call mips
massively multi-introducinary problems
how do we go after drug Discovery how do
we go after some of the hardest problems
in National Security how do we go after
infrastructure that is going to be able
to spin up and take up care of a problem
like we've seen around covid just like
that how are we going to address
problems around education or climate or
so many other different areas what would
that look like if we dedicate just a
little bit of our time for that maybe
some of you are going to dedicate your
companies the things all the different
ideas like Pete talked about like what
would that look like if we dedicated
time and energy to help work on those
the hardest problems today need you
because your kids and your kids kids are
gonna need it
and then finally I'm going to end on
this which is data science is a team
sport
one of my ass for you is we're a
community we're a team
that means we should act like a team we
should look out for each other we should
help each other
and start really asking what can we do
to support each other
none of us got here on our own I did not
definitely did not get here on my own I
have come from an incredibly
privileged opportunity of so many people
supporting me along the way and I've had
amazing teams I've ever been able to
work with and so my ask of you
is there is somebody here in this
community maybe they're in this room
maybe they're out there somewhere else
who needs help
what would this look like if you gave
them a little bit of time many of you
have already done office hours here what
if you did a little bit of office hours
with them
maybe there's somebody in your
organization who's struggling a little
bit who's raising their hand and what if
you just gave them a little bit of time
and energy to help
that's what a good teammate would do
that's what a good citizen would do
that's what a good friend would do
that's what a good partner would do
that's how we should act as a community
those things is really what's going to
carry us forward
and that fundamentally I wouldn't just
say thank you to all of you that have
been working on these problems working
in this Community Helping make us all
successful and really have adopted this
mindset of data science as a team sport
we couldn't do it without you guys so
thank you
foreign
[Music]